anh alo alo cho các bạn
ờ ờ
hôm nay tôi thấy là giọng Tối về đỡ hơn
rồi Nếu mà
à à
thì à
ở đầu tiên à
Vì sao sao hôm nay các bạn nghỉ lễ nghỉ
Hôm nay trà có người thì bắt đầu được
nghỉ rồi không thì cũng Ngắm Mai được
nghỉ
thì các bạn cụ thể về quê có thứ
thì hôm nay mình cũng kiểu định là chỉ
giới thiệu qua cách làm tài liệu một lần
nữa để cho các bạn nào quên cách làm tất
cả là đón hai thứ ba thì nó khác đón mổ
một tí về cách hành tài liệu theo kiểu
nó sẽ
nhất là đương nhiên là mình sẽ yêu cầu
mà khát khao hơn cũng như là ở đây Để tí
mình sẽ chỉ nói gì khác và liệu đoán một
một tí thôi
a tiếp theo là à
anh ở đấy những
ở giới thiệu qua xong rồi tâm sự nhắn gì
đó cho các bạn kiểu thoải mái mình cũng
thoải mái thì da mình không biết được ạ
là có nhiều cái thì mình vẫn có thể dậy
được thì mình sẽ trả lời có một bạn vải
vừa hỏi thêm một cái thì mình sẽ chia sẻ
code vào dạy qua được nhưng mà có nhiều
cái thì mình nghĩa là bây giờ đến cái
ngưỡng mà các bạn cũng gọi là tâm tâm
biết một chút tự thử rồi thì đủ để làm
đồ án rồi là đủ để tối ưu cái đoán các
bạn rồi thì mình cũng không cần phải dậy
gì đó nhiều quá nữa còn về sau thì mình
thấy cái gì hay những cái mèo các thử
thì mình sẽ chia sẻ thêm à trên kênh bit
caught sau đây là các bạn có gì Các bạn
cứ tham gia King disco của mình để mà
cẩu
tổng hợp các tài liệu lãnh cả các thứ
thận chứa có cá những sự kiện này cái sự
kiện offline như tim à
community ở Hà em kiểm tra rồi school
curve Chu tim committee thì các bạn có
thể đăng ký nha
à à
kể
bây giờ mình sẽ phép mình tâm sự một tí
về Spider Man Ừ nếu mà các bạn nào chưa
biết về cái spurs em nó là nó diễn đàn
thì nó dễ đàn ở trên web nó lá giống như
là gì
em nói nó như những diễn đàn Bình thường
là anh sẽ có đăng bài các số thứ cái nó
Ừ cái mình thấy à Nó gần giống nhất Nó
sẽ giống khá giống mê đi em rất là sao
rẽ là cái bài đang ở trên này nó khá là
chọn lọc một tí cho các bạn xem qua
không biết người ta thay đổi giao diện
chưa ở
cấp thứ thứ trên này có 3 dạng nhá chứ
này đa dạng đôi khi là từ chủ yếu đương
nhiên vẫn chủ yếu là những người kiểu
dạng là cũng gọi là chuyên gia ở một
lĩnh vực hoặc cả người ta có góc nhìn gì
đó gọi khá ổn thôi vẫn phải qua bài
duyệt thì phải chứ không hiểu dạng là
đang xuống được bởi vì đăng suông những
cái người đọc trên này cũng đã là những
người trí thức nên là từ bình luận được
cả mọi thứ thì sẽ hiểu dạng là ông bà
đang guitar tình bị ném đá tới tấp nên
chắc là không có ai đăng trên này Chỗ
tạo là gấu kiến thức sai lệch được
anh thì OK để giới thiệu qua với Style
năm Thế còn
nhiên tôi Đề cập về cái bên này
ý thì cái bên bên này thời ra từ lâu đã
kiểu khá thích bên YouTube committee
phải di tim kulti có cộng đồng đấy các
bạn là cậu rất là sôi động và đông đông
đảo thì rất nhiều bên cũng muốn hợp tác
để mà đăng bài cũng kiểu để làm việc lâu
dài các kiểu thứ thì bên này Hôm qua tôi
mới qua bên đấy thì cái này bật mí cho
bé uống trước thôi cho vì sau sẽ sẽ có
thể trình khai sau cái bật mí thế này
thì
sau buổi nói chuyện hôm qua tôi thấy có
cái rất hay bị spam này sắp sửa chữ hai
cái kiểu dạng hệ thống kéo di linh tức
là học online kiểu dáng như thế này
nhưng mà sẽ có các khóa học thì bên đời
có với tôi về để thử A để để làm một cái
khóa lập trình và cũng sẽ như thế này nó
lập trình
lập trình web từ đầu cho Ừ Bây giờ cứ
ghé toàn bộ những cái gì tôi thể dạy
được thì tôi sẽ dạy dạy và tôi đang cái
khóa học ở trên kênh đấy thì
ở đây cũng là một cái ngày hôm trước
ngày hôm trước tôi còn nói mấy ông rồi
tự nhiên ở gần đây tự nhiên gần đây là
tôi cảm thấy là
Ừ ừ nếu mà theo nhiều bạn nữ nhiều bạn
mới Tín thì sẽ là kiểu dạng sẽ hiểu bảo
là Ờ tí hiểm vũ trụ hay lờ thứ nhưng mà
có hai cái này hay Cái này rất là hay nó
Tao vừa mới hôm trước rồi mới nói và tôi
vừa mình nghĩ các thứ tôi cần phải bổ
sung các thứ thứ nên tôi bảo là kiểu gì
cũng sẽ mang lại khóa học của tôi bởi vì
à Nó chưa đủ chuyên nghiệp cũng như là
ờ ờ kỹ năng sư phạm tôi chưa ổn thì tôi
sẽ định dạy về về dạy bên FPT một thời
gian sau đó thì mình vững hơn mình có
tài liệu cũng nhờ cách dạy ở bên ấy mưa
đêm tôi sẽ ốp về để tôi dậy lại một khóa
nữa ở trên kênh của tôi đúng ạ thì Style
này bên Spears này bảo sẽ hỗ trợ tôi cái
việc quay nó cả chỉnh sửa video để mà
cái việc những đề tài những cái video ấy
nó sẽ rất là chất lượng để và đang trên
nền tảng của họ và đương nhiên Đương
nhiên nhưng mà khi tôi đang thì nó sẽ là
miễn phí như bên đấy cũng khuyến khích
tôi là sẽ kiểu thu phí gì đó để mà cho
họ cảm thấy trân trọng cái gì đó vẫn
điều cốc như hồi trước tôi có đề cập rồi
nên tôi nghĩ à Để tôi sẽ thu phí nhưng
tôi sẽ có thể hoàn phí
E với
anh Bởi vì để tôi nghĩa là đặc biệt cái
giai đoạn chính giai đoạn này thì nó mới
đúng kiểu cần cam kết này nó là xã Đạo
làm đồ án
ờ
nghĩa là tôi sẽ đang ở trên đấy nó sẽ
bao gồm cả lập trình cơ bản
họ lập trình website cơ bản không ạ cho
đến lập trình website chuyên sâu chẳng
hạn thì cả 2 cái đều sẽ là miễn phí
nhưng để cam kết làm đồ án và bao gồm
kiểu để mà chấm và chữa gì đó thì chắc
là sẽ mất phí mất phí thêm thì chả tương
đối thôi thì gà không quan trọng với cái
phí lắm Bởi tôi định là nếu mà bạn đấy
chỉ cần hoàn thành hoàn thành cái lúc
đầu cam kép là sẽ làm xong kế web đấy
thì sẽ trả lại phí nên là không không
quan tâm thì cái tiền nong gì ở đây mà
Đấy chị một sự cam kết của bạn ấy thôi
thì thôi Nghĩa
anh không những à không những là kiểu sẽ
cam kết kiểu
khiến lại cam kết hơn bạn chuẩn trọng
hơn thứ hai đó là thậm chí là có thể
đăng ký theo nhóm và nếu mà người nào mà
ở lại đấy những người nào lại sẽ được
trả phí của người kia cứ Các bạn cứ hình
dung kiểu như này đó là kiểu ví dụ là sự
là bảo mỗi người đóng 500 em ạ trong tất
cả không biết đọc tay dài với mấy ông
nhưng mà kết thúc ngủ khóa chắc là tôi
Nghĩa Lộ
bình thường ờ
à mỗi người đóng 500 hai người làm cùng
một nhóm bây giờ giả sử là
kết thúc cái
khi kết thúc cái dự án đấy trong vòng
hai ba tháng Nếu mà tự nhiên có một bạn
vào để bỏ Thì 500 còn lại nói chung là
sau Kết thúc Hạ 3 tháng đi thì mà làm
xong thì tôi sẽ trả 1 triệu như cho cái
bạn còn lại những kiểu thế
anh béo hiểu đi ra ông ạ
à à
lại cho người làm mà kiểu
cam kết
cam kết ở lại thôi vợ chồng biết giải
thích như nào cho có phải dễ hiểu hơn
nữa đại khái như thế nó kiểu dạng là đôi
khi chúng ta bỏ tiền ra để có một sự cam
kết ở Ồ
không Tôi là ví dụ một cái số tiền được
lượng vậy thôi Chứ thứ nhất là có ai cứ
lấy tiền của mình ông đâu Từ trước hay
Tôi không có ý định thì lấy cả thơ kể cả
sao rồi Nhiều người có bảo anh chỉ cần
kinh doanh thì 10.000 một người cũng có
thể kiếm được tiền rồi sẽ chẳng hạn thế
tôi không Không mục đích thứ nhất là tôi
không kham mày phải chất lượng thế mạnh
thứ hai là may mà tôi vẫn đủ sống đây là
thấy ngay tội không quan trọng cái đấy
lắm thứ ba đó là
có những ngày thứ mà liên quan đam mê
của mình mình động trên bạc nó rất là
rất nhiều vấn đề nên là nên là tôi hạn
chế tránh được thế nào tránh cái việc là
đóng tiền ở đây xong rồi trả lại cho mấy
ông gần như là không được cái gì cả từ
đấy mà gần như là cốt là kiểu để cho mấy
ông tự cam kết bạn nhau và tôi cảm thấy
là thế này còn cam kết cho bạn đồng hành
của mấy ông quan trọng như thế bởi vì
tôi thấy rất nhiều nhóm
ờ ờ Cậu tôi ghét cho nhóm đánh rồi xong
rồi tự nhiên Bạn Đồng Hành kia bò làm
tôi cũng cảm thấy khó nói với bạn còn
lại và bạn còn lại cũng lại nếu hiểu đi
dọn thì thế này là tới nghĩa cách này
cách để cho mấy ông tự cam kết trước khi
đăng ký một cái gì đó đứng yên à Không
ai muốn bỏ cả đúng ạ Không ai và toàn bộ
là từ trước ai trên tinh thần miễn phí
và tự nguyện ta cả tự do thoải mái đúng
bạn nếu mà chính vì tự do thoải mái thế
nó vẫn có cái gì đó lấn cấn ở đây mà ông
méo hiểu đâu ạ Nó không có cam kết thật
thế nên là nó cũng còn thiếu đi sự thiếu
trân trọng đã thử thứ chứ thực tế thực
tế nhá đó à À
có rất nhiều cách Nếu bạn sử muốn khu
tiên của mấy ông thì tôi vẫn không không
thu tiền của mấy ông Nếu sạc xử thế có
rất nhiều cách để mà túi tiền với ông
bằng cái khác đó là giả sử là đấy giới
thiệu công công việc trong mấy ông thì
tôi được tiền hoa hồng các thủ thứ II
anh đúng một tháng lương Nửa tháng lương
của mấy ông thế thì tha hồ mà có nghĩa
cứ dạy miễn phí Rồi rồi giới thiệu việc
làm thôi cái kiểu thế chứ không không
thu của mình đang làm cái gì cả em với
ông
cha mẹ ông thứ nhất là Mẹo cứ chỉ không
không nên quan tâm về tiền bạc mà thứ
hai là những quan tâm đi học cho bản
thân các thứ thứ và có một sự cam kết
thôi
anh ấy lại hiểu chứ nhưng mà Đấy đấy à
khóa sau mừng khóa này thì hôm nay hiểu
biết thế hệ
à à
về
thiết kế cơ sở dữ liệu phần Note phần À
cái nốt trong điểm danh thế nào á Thực
ra thì nếu mà em xem cái phần mềm cũ của
anh thì đúng là thấy anh có phần
cái ghi chú ở dưới ấy nhưng anh không
lưu lại ở trong bảng thực sự nó có rất
nhiều lấy điểm danh mà không còn liên
quan không không không cần phải điện
không cần ghi chú gì cả đến thời ca Cột
đấy nó sẽ bị thừa Đây là cái việc chúa
dưới này của anh nói anh lưu lại đó thẳm
trong tâm cái user và nguyên dùng thế
thôi thế được
với đại học chính quy ở có rất nhiều bạn
có kiểu dạng vẫn còn phải học về chương
trường tôi thậm chí à các bạn còn đang
học trái ngành chứ kiểu rất nhiều cái
vấn đề Tôi hiểu chứ Đây là thực ra ngay
từ đầu là thứ nhất là đăng ký tự nguyện
nên thành ra là
mô hình ta là kiểu các bạn lúc đầu đã có
sự cam kết nhất định và tự nguyện thật
sự rồi nhưng mà nhưng mà cái thiệt nhất
ở đây đó không phải là các bạn cũng
không phải là tôi mà là chính là người
đồng hành cùng các bạn nếu hiểu vấn đề
ông ạ Thế nên là cái cái cái kia gần như
là cái một cái gì đó cậu cứ cho là một
cái lúc đầu một cái cam kết cho chính
cái bạn đồng hành các bạn là cảm thấy an
tâm bạn sẽ đồng hành còn việc á Giả sử
dụng như ông nghỉ thôi người ta được mỗi
500 một người ta phải gánh 23 tháng thì
ra tôi cảm thấy nó con số bé để tôi làm
ví dụ thế
bạn mà Thậm chí con mà không biết bạn
nào tôi không Không nói tên đúng không
Nếu mà có bạn thì tôi ghép nhóm xong rồi
xong rồi à không liên lạc đứa bạn ấy nữa
luôn
game nhóm xong thôi ý đấy bạn mất tích
hoàn toàn luôn đấy có rất nhiều bạn ở
tôi không liên lạc được nữa ngoài những
cái bạn một thực sự có có lý do ra nên
nên là thành ra là kiểu cái này vẫn là
một cái thứ nó lấn cấn nhé có hiểu đâu ạ
Nên là bởi vì nó miễn phí và nó tự do
nên thành ra các bạn thích kiểu chỉ cần
điền ở trong người form sâu rồi tôi tôi
kiểu dạng kiểu ghép vào là xong ấn vào
đun với vào xong nên mọi thứ nó dễ dàng
quá khiến cho tiền cho kiểu có ai đó
Điền một cái phom bừa cũng có thể vào
được
những dấu hiệu cho là những cái thực
người thực sự cần những các thứ nghệ
Thực sự cậu giá là nghiêm túc với cái dự
án đương nhiên là cái dự án này 30
nghiêm túc rồi ông học thì ông thể học
cật Nhã và ông học trong một thời gian
dài được là kiểu dạng là học khóa tôi
cái gì có thể kéo dài lâu hơn được chưa
cần đồ án thì vẫn phải hoàn thiện trong
một khoảng thời gian để mình để mình
hiểu được thế nào mới thực sự làm đồ án
tốt hơn chứ đồ án và ông làm kéo dài quá
thì cũng biết là ông tự lạ tự khiến bản
thân mình lười thứ hai là ông không tâm
huyết hoàn toàn và nó được đoán là phải
mất ăn mất ngủ với nó đâu ạ
ờ ờ
qua thế và nó sẽ là khóa sau lấy chỗ nào
tôi nói thế với mấy ông ở kiểu thông báo
thôi chứ thực ra mấy ông học sau quá này
rồi cũng chẳng có ý nghĩa gì mấy Nếu mà
Nhưng mà bên spies em đấy thì thậm chí ở
bên đấy sẽ có thỉnh thoảng tôi có thể
qua bên đấy quay làm tốt cáp hoặc à gì
gì đó nữa tôi hướng đến
xu hướng đến dậy à
vì vậy là một phần thỉnh thoảng về sao
vẫn sẽ dậy này cốt ở trên kênh này như
về sau vẫn có thể bóc áp và làm vlog Nếu
như ông ạ thì tôi sẽ hợp tác được bên
đấy bên anh sẽ hỗ trợ tôi cả chỉnh sửa
gì ràng là của quá tốt luôn thử mình
thiếu thì đã có
ở bên đấy ở rất giỏi về xây dựng hình
ảnh được tôi sẽ nhiều rạp mình thấy rất
nhiều Ok Đấy đấy một cái hay mà tôi hôm
trước tôi đang lấn cấn thì đã gặp đúng
đúng người đúng tiếp cái Cai lần thứ hai
vào là hôm trước thì tôi có nói các bạn
đó là bên FPT academy bên đấy Kiểu tôi
sẽ về dậy bên đấy nhưng mà
nhờ Ở bên đấy bảo là kiến thức kiến thức
lý thuyết của tôi vẫn còn hơi yếu bởi vì
a vì cậu tôi về các bạn thì tôi vẫn học
ở trường nghề ra kết hợp việc đọc xa là
sách toàn mình có sách hưởng Hồi đấy ở
Bình thường tôi toàn bộ những cái thứ
tôi dậy là tôi chủ yếu là từ thực hành
xong rồi đọc thêm trên vai diễn đàn chứ
không có một cái gì qua một quy chuẩn bị
cả đây là khi tôi bị đang bị khá hồng để
lý thuyết cái bên Xperia Z còn web thì
thực ra web chẳng có cái gì mà dậy đi
trước cả nên là ờ
Ừ tự nhiên sau hôm đó vài ngày thì tôi
có chắc à đương nhiên là thường hay bảo
ở tín hiệu Vũ Trụ hay gì đó Nhưng thực
tế là do là mình mình là con người như
nào xong mình hay tiếp xúc những con
người như nào mình hay tìm kiếm những
cái gì đây là sẽ gặp những điều đấy điển
hình là tôi có tự nhiên lâu rồi thì phải
hơn nửa năm rồi Tôi kết bạn một anh anh
đấy là bên A
ờ ờ bên cầu dạng là
khi tôi chẳng nhớ cụ thể tên của cái ạ
nhóm đấy nhưng đại khái là đại khái là
anh đấy chuyên Đào tạo về SQL thế thôi
nhớ chính xác kiểu xanh lá Thế thì hôm
hôm trước có để là anh ấy vừa đăng cái
chỗ dạng là đang muốn tổ chức các lớp
khóa học Em quê ở đây là ít béo chuyên
sâu nhé chứ không phải là cơ bản đâu đấy
Tôi đang có cái video Tôi đang mở lên
mình xem đây này thì ờ
Ừ thì hôm trước
anh đấy đang thấy rồi tôi đang tôi đang
đăng ký Tôi đang xem Mỹ nhất một buổi
anh ấy xem thế nào là thấy toàn bộ kiến
thức các thứ sớm mở mang thêm nhiều hết
nhiều phết chắc à và có một tí sai về
hồi trước tôi dậy lúc say thì cũng dùng
từ sai đúng thiếu gì cũng đúng Nghe
thiếu thiếu nên là thực ra bản chất là
chiếu thì nó sẽ dẫn đến sai và hiểu sai
lệch đã có thứ về ví dụ về Index em ạ ấy
các thứ thứ chả là về sau chắc chắn là
cái khóa vì sau tôi sẽ phải dạy cẩn thận
lại các thứ thứ và nó lý thuyết thứ cho
nó chuẩn
ẩm thực hành mình hiểu dễ hơn rồi nhưng
mà để mình tối ưu nó thì bắt buộc đúng
là lý thuyết mình phải hứa rõ thật đấy
thì thế đấy Tôi vô tình một cách kiểu ý
hữu ý hay gì gì đó gặp được những người
để hỗ trợ cho mình sẽ thử thứ khá ổn
trong sự nghiệp đúng năm nay là một năm
khẳng định đây tôi tâm sự nốt hôm nay em
15 triệu rất nhiều biến chuyển trong
cuộc đời của tôi từ việc là xin lấy vợ
cho đấy nữa à à
cũng bị ảnh hưởng khá nhiều ở dạng là
mình suy nghĩ khá nhiều Xong rồi đừng
phá à Tôi định cẩu
ạ Bạn ấy năm nay xích lại vợ thật
và sau đây là cuối cùng mình thành nhà
tôi định dẫn đến 29 30 thì mới lấy tiếp
theo là về sự nghiệp thì năm nay
có rất nhiều cái vấn đề bức ở trên công
ty gần đây cũng biết là hi vọng từ giờ
cuối năm không bị dính nữa như khiến cho
tôi có khá nhiều bài học và kiểu rút
kinh nghiệm hơn các xưởng may mà bây giờ
còn bị sớm như tôi từng nó là gặp bây
giờ là còn bị còn hơn là về sau về sau
của công ty Phát Triển võ chưởng rồi rồi
bị dính bước nữa chắc à Chỗ Không không
Đây nổi đấy à tiếp theo là
gì nhỉ ờ
ở đây về sự nghiệp đã xong rồi tự nhiên
ở bên bên A FPT liên hệ để tôi về dậy
như thế này đúng ạ tiếp theo là bị spam
cũng hỗ trợ của tôi về các thứ thứ này
đấy
anh nói chung hả Còn thêm vài cái thứ
nữa Đúng rồi Đúng rồi Đúng rồi hồi trước
ở tôi có kể với ông chưa nhở tôi định mở
quán cà phê thì tớ định tôi hồi đấy 24
tuổi tôi cam kết 5 năm nữa một quán cà
phê là 29 tuổi thì và và tôi còn không
biết được tôi tôi kém về mặt quản lý
kinh doanh để thờ gà tội không biết được
là
mình sẽ làm như thế nào mình chỉ có ý
tưởng thôi và mình chỉ có kiểu thực sự
là muốn mở Thôi thì tự nhiên năm nay bạn
tôi từ bên Nhật về bạn đấy cậu lại muốn
kinh doanh và bạn ấy cũng nói chung là
tính rất hợp tôi bằng tuổi tôi cũng là
dân công nghệ nhá phải là mà ai ở bên
Nhật 2 năm liền Nhưng mà áp lực quá bạn
ơi muốn nghỉ công nghệ thể về để kinh
doanh vì đầu óc bạn ấy giỏi bên gà người
giỏi người ta đa-zi-năng Anh muốn nhảy
vào động được đấy nghe muốn làm giàu
thích thì làm giàu được đấy Ừ đấy thịt
Ừ thì bạn ấy về đây bạn ấy mở quán quán
ăn trước để mà học cách quản lý cả Lấy
vốn đã xong rồi Bạn ấy cũng định là 2
năm nữa sẽ mở quán cà phê thì tôi sẽ
chung vốn với bạn ấy sau đấy lẽ là mọi
thứ đang rất là theo đúng kế hoạch thuốc
đầu của tôi mỗi tội nó nhanh hơn rất
nhiều và tổng hợp hết vào trong năm nay
rất nhiều
mọi thứ luôn anh cần muốn mở quán cà phê
à à
thì kệ người thôi hai ngày nữa ở trong
Sài Gòn tôi sẽ có vợ tôi sẽ vào đấy nhờ
tôi không có ý định là vào đấy ở lo tôi
định về sau nếu là lý tưởng hát Thôi tôi
mà kể
tôi không biết tôi kể về sau của tôi
nghỉ hưu ở đâu Tự nhiên mấy ông về cùng
về ở đấy nửa vui nửa giờ vui là Ừ thì
thì đương nhiên của anh em các kiểu thì
cũng vui Ở đấy Hơi cả ngạt thở hơi thở
nhạc 9 giờ tắt máy tắt đèn đưa còn mỗi
lần nữa rồi cũng chẳng có ai ra ngoài
được à Nhưng mà nếu mà dở là vì sao tự
nhiên anh em về đây đông quá thì tự
nhiên giá đất để tăng thì tôi không có
chỗ để ở mất Thế là tôi thế sao vì sao
tôi thông báo sau
thấy không biết từ giờ đến cuối năm nó
sẽ nhạc à đấy nhưng mà tháng 13 tháng 9
rồi Đúng không Một tháng nữa là tôi sẽ
tôi vừa nạp bé vừa song song đó là một
tháng nữa là tôi sẽ vào Sài Gòn thì để
mà tội tổ chức offline đấy chắc là tí
rồi sẽ liên hệ bên FPT để mà xem Liệt kê
lại mình hỗ trợ hay các thứ thứ đấy hỗ
trợ đồng mình cái gì n thứ để mà sau đó
thì mình sẽ mở cái phone đăng đăng ký
cho các bạn đăng ký để mà offline rồi
chứ Ở Hồ Chí Minh
à à
ý thì buổi offline này sẽ cho có thể có
thể sẽ có cả anh Mạnh Tuấn Việt Thảo thì
có thể bay vào có vài người có thể sân
bay vào đấy có thể lần này sẽ có anh
Mạnh Tuấn và lần này anh Mạnh Tuấn thì
sẽ lần đầu tiên mà đông thế mà còn mang
mạnh tuấn mấy lần trước thì mới chỉ có
đã từ xuất hiện Anh mặc Tuấn buổi
offline một hai lần gì đó rồi nhưng mà
là lần này khá chọn lọc và có quen các
thứ Còn lần này đông thật
hả Khi nào anh nghỉ hưu con bộ địa điểm
thì các môn theo loa cũng hơn của chị
Cái hợp hay ra mình dân công nghệ mà
mình thích nhảy đâu nhỉ tôi chắc là tôi
sẽ về một cái thành phố ở đó để ý khi
ông Nghĩa không thể về hẳn vùng nông
thôn theo cờ lại xa xôi hẻo lánh không
có mạng được và bây giờ chỗ nào có mạng
những ý tôi là kiểu tối vẫn quen được
với tôi vẫn quen kiểu cái sự xô bồ ấy
chẳng qua không không Hà Nội hay ở Sài
Gòn xô bồ quá để có thể nghỉ hưu thôi
Cái Huế
có tập thể dục hay gì không ạ một câu
hỏi rất khó vừa mới ngủ dậy không ạ
Không thích trả lời ông câu này như thế
nào nhưng mà
hôm qua tôi
khi chúng tôi chia sẻ hấp thôi vẫn vốn
từ trước hay vẫn chưa sẻ rằng đó là cậu
hôm qua tôi ăn tối xong thôi tự nhiên
anh em kiểu bà hôm nay nghỉ được nghỉ là
rủ đi chơi xong rồi tôi Kiều bảo anh em
kiếm quán nét về tôi hơn hơn một năm hồi
trưa ngồi quán net đấy sao sau đó thì
cuối cùng anh ngay mà tìm lại được còn
schieber ở mạng mà còn gần nhau mình ạ
Đấy các thứ xịn Còn chị ở đây ở điểm máy
móc thì tôi ra tôi không quan trọng lắm
nhưng đúng mặt phím cơ và có Kê tay rất
thích mấy ông lấy ti hiểu có cái tay do
bàn phím nó kiểu sẽ đỗ đỡ hơn cho tay
thứ hai nó là
ghế cũng ổn và không hút thuốc nữa họ
không hút thuốc phòng điều hòa cũng hút
thuốc theo thứ tự ở chỗ mọi thứ đều tự
cho ăn ở đây giá được ra đời nhưng giá
không phải bình dân sinh viên nhưng mà
chính như thế nó sẽ chọn lọc được đó là
kiểu một mình đi làm rồi thật cao mình Ừ
Quan trọng thiệt mặc lắm nữa mình quan
trọng là kiểu khi đi chơi một sự thoải
mái mình không muốn được xung quanh Quá
ồn ào hay là chỗ nhiều thành phần gì đó
không phải Viking bà chịu vì kinh bây
giờ mà táo rồi à
vừa bị lũ lụt do Đà Lạt không phải là
nơi để mà tôi tôi cả nhân tôi thấy không
phải nơi để nghỉ hưu cho lắm Đúng là ký
hiệu các thử một thủ ổn nhưng mà Đấy hợp
nơi du lịch ông ạ Bây giờ tự nhận mọi
thứ người ta về bắt đầu đông đúc cái thủ
thứ mệt mỏi
ờ ờ
tôi qua đấy Lâu lắm rồi cậu mới chơi
game nhưng mà cũng không cũng không chơi
được mấy game hiểu moba các thứ nữa
chiến thuật nữa Mà chơi game bắn súng
Gunny game bắn súng lúc tôi cảm thấy hai
điểm mà nó sẽ rất nhẹ đầu chẳng cần tính
toán thì cả lên bắn nhau cá vui giải trí
đấy Ờ
Ê bà khi chơi game Tôi là con người khác
luôn tới chửi bậy các thử thoải mái vui
đi chơi không được sinh viên còn mình
còn trẻ trâu hơn cho sinh viên cái thứ
sau đó tôi chơi đến 12 giờ đêm rồi à
Thằng bạn đó lại dù có quán kèm theo bài
vài có chỗ nào cũng đông hơn 10 người để
mà qua quán chơi zing game chơi game và
kiểu dạo là cầu dạng là
có một bộ bài trên đời có khá nhiều câu
hỏi hơi bị nhiều cảm nhiều cái Họ thử
thách thứ gì đó Thế bạn một là trả lời
Hoàng làm theo được cách hay uống tiểu
sử đưa tôi với Không rượu bia lên tôi
cũng chỉ trả mồi các thử thử không thích
rượu bia gì cả nhưng mà chơi Tận năm sáu
giờ sáng hôm nay sau đó thì cũng vui nói
chung à
mỗi tội là mấy người kia Tính là cho là
mình lớn tuổi hơn họ không biết như là
đội chơi họ về hơi kém và họ ca nhạc
sống liên khúc
Mấy ông chị chơi Mấy cái game để béo
ngoài kiểu 3 và buổi offline gần đây cái
buổi Hòn Hà Nội này Hôm hôm qua chở để
mô để tôi đi xem mà cậu xem Triển khai
ổn mới không nhá Nó buổi offline Hà Nội
này bắt buộc là sẽ có chơi kiểu có cái
lúc mày đi cà phê này sẽ có một tí Zing
game ấy nhá nên là tôi hả Tôi muốn mọi
người sẽ hiểu giao lưu thử tôi ghi hàng
đây à
và cả Bắc Ninh thì đó tính sao
có mini game
Để xem hôm đấy tâm trạng mọi người thế
nào kết hợp với mấy người dám chơi không
Thì thì những cái link game những cái
kiểu nó một là có hỏi cảm hay những thử
thách tôi khi nào nó có thể đơn giản là
kiểu hôn Nam Á đối phương thì đã khác
hay hơn rồi má đồng giới khác giới gì đó
đánh son tập thứ mấy ông đừng có ngại
mấy cái đấy tôi biết được là nhiều hướng
nội các thứ hoặc là mấy ông còn chưa và
mất nụ hôn đầu có những điển hình một
ông mẹ ông sinh viên hôm qua nhưng mà ý
chính vì vậy ông kiểu cứ giữ như thế
Thằng em nó sẽ mãi không giờ mất với ông
phải thả máy lên và cái việc thoải mái
đấy Chả ai nhớ cả chỉ có cũng lắm và ông
nhớ nhớ ông nhớ về sau ông sẽ không ân
hận gì cả ông sẽ cảm thấy là nói một cái
trải nghiệm một cái một cái kỷ niệm gì
vui nó không bị đừng có biến nó thành
gượng ép quá đối thôi nhé Chỉ có gạt
rượu bia nhiều nó bị mang tính chất
lượng ép các thứ thứ còn những cái việc
là kiểu chơi các thử thử bạn bè với nhau
này thì mình nên xóa nên vui chưa bây
giờ giả sử chơi
chơi thôi Ai bảo không không làm đâu Cái
thứ thì nó sẽ bị quá nhạt Nếu hiểu do
trong cuộc chơi Không nên mà tự không xe
tải cẩu nó bị nó bị kéo tôi thôi cách
à à
Em ở chỗ nào đấy xong rồi tôi
7 giờ sáng tôi mới về
Khi mà mọi người bình minh mọi người ra
ngoài tập thể dục dưỡng sinh để bắt đầu
một ngày mới thì thôi bắt đầu về nhà đi
ngủ à ấy ra đi ăn sáng rồi đi ngủ đấy
giống yêu hồi trước tôi des thâu đêm
Lucy tội làm hay làm sau đấy Tớ không
khuyến khích mấy ông làm tất cả những
cái đi vừa rồi nhưng mà tôi khi nó là
một cái trải nghiệm gì đó Tuổi Trẻ ông
làm được người già đó cũng không làm
được vì ông sẽ quá quá sức đấy Tôi nghĩ
ở đây tất cả mấy ông nhiều trẻ với ông
có thể một lần khử thử gửi thế Nó không
có cái gì đó gọi là hư hỏng hay là ngoan
ngoãn hay gì đó đây cả thì nó vẫn trẻ
trải nghiệm và tôi thấy à nó không để
lại hậu quả sau này nên mà nói với hai
kiểu gì thử
anh mua đồ ăn rồi các thứ có thể không
rượu bia không khuyến khích người uống
rượu bia nhưng mà
trò chơi Những cái trò chơi kiểu dạng
này khiến cho chúng ta kiểu giao lưu
thoải mái hơn với nhau thì vẫn không
thích mà tới mục đích của bác game đấy à
rồi thì nói chung là càng ngày hôm nay
tôi chỉ có mới thôi Ăn ngủ này chưa vận
động gì cả - đúng cái đoạn mà
cái đoạn Ừ đúng là có sáng nay lúc mà ba
bốn giờ sáng thì phải lúc mà chơi game
thì tôi bị phạt à Tôi phải
chống đẩy đã đứng lên ngồi xuống trước
mặt một bạn nữ cho nó kiểu dạo này cậu
không đi em khiêu gợi gió Ừ Thế lúc đấy
tôi được tính tập thể dục lâu lắm cô dâu
không tập thể dục luôn rồi tự nhiên mình
phải được nghiên cứu sống đến bây giờ
chân vẫn còn hơi đau
Ừ nhưng mà thấy chú ở xa quá
cho Nokia nhưng mà đúng chơi từ 12 giờ
đến 5 giờ sáng biết thì dù không a rất
nhiều con gái luôn
Mở bài Như Có mũi ba thằng con trai
tắm bạn nữ
đi làm rồi đụng vào máy game kiểu moba
thì đúng à Cậu nó Nhung cái moba ngoài
vì chính luật ra còn phải nắm rõ được là
cái bây giờ nó đang như nào nữa Thành
nha hả cậu tôi đưa tôi chỉ xem game thôi
Tôi không chơi được cái thứ Chơi game
bắn súng cho đỡ phải nghĩ không ạ Và Thơ
Ca bây giờ chúng ta quan trọng không
phải chơi game mà để cho nghỉ một tháng
qua hay gì đó nữa mà mình thường anh mua
đã tưởng niệm lại cái thôi Hiểu cái gì
đó Hay là mình mình có xả nó làm cái gì
đó xả hơi và và cậu mình
tạm quên đi sẽ tại gỗ rất nhiều vấn đề
thôi Nhiều lúc tôi rất tình tứ Đi net mà
Đấy vui nét buồn đi net Fujinet là đây
án chưa hiểu ví dụ vào ngày lễ nghỉ lễ
này tôi thường ai cũng đi nét bởi vì nằm
gì có hồi đấy làm gì có người yêu thì
ghét thôi đi với anh em tâm sự thứ bây
giờ thì à ừ ừ
chị thơ tình đi nét cao thủ hướng nhờ
Quan trọng là vẫn có người đi cùng nhỉ
vui Còn nếu mà đi lên một mình như hơi
buồn ạ
khi yêu thường ai chẳng có máy ở nhà nó
không ạ
ok Ờ
các bạn đang tạo không Tâm sự hỏi đã gì
cả Mình xin phép và trả lời câu này
con này bạn bạn ơi à
để chiều nay tao gửi cho bạn đấy Sao lại
bảo là của anh Anh phải chữa cái này cho
các bạn khác bởi vì có thể nhiều bạn còn
chưa biết ok thì để tôi chữa sẽ á
ở đầu tiên thì tôi vẫn sẽ cài à
a taste for để cho mấy ông tiện xem nhé
giới thiệu Xem câu truy vấn các kiểu thứ
thì mình biết được tối ưu câu truy vấn
liên lạc hồng ngoại
Cái này là vào ô
he he crank-e
truy vấn đúng không Đây bây giờ xử tôi
mở về BB lên đi ạ
Ừ vợ lại bên này
thời trang giày viện code
anh không Anh lại không bị mày cái đầu
lắm là đủ ở còn không có thời gian để
làm những cái kiểu tạm
bì các thử thứ đúng là thỉnh thoảng xem
vài khóa học tất cả đọc tài liệu có thử
thôi chứ không có thời gian để mở cậu
lên sạch lên Cốt lại một cái gì đó nên
chứng Pad bố Rách của tôi gần đây tôi
còn đang bị trì hoãn
I stop này mình có bảng cái sốt rồi mày
nghỉ à Đúng rồi chỉ chưa cài bất cứ thôi
ok à
bố mẹ tôi dễ hình dung ah tôi có u dâu ở
đây đúng không cho tôi có bài đang ở đây
rồi chứ Chuyển rảnh thì thôi tôi có u xơ
và có mày đang đúng ạ Thế bây giờ tôi
Giả sử Tôi muốn lấy ra tất tất cả bài
đăng của ozo trong tháng này hoặc trong
ngày hôm nay như bạn đấy làm thì sẽ làm
như thế nào đây Ờ
trang Index web Adele
à à
anh ở đây thì đang trả về toàn bộ danh
sách tất cả ozer đúng chứ nhưng mà tôi
muốn lấy thêm một cái nữa
là chị ra hai cái nữa đó là tôi muốn lấy
thêm
toàn bộ bài đăng của bạn thấy đăng trong
tháng này và trong ngày hôm nay tớ ra
mới xa thang mới hai thằng nó bằng nhau
nhưng mà tôi muốn xem câu truy vấn nó sẽ
ở như thế nào thì thằng para nó sẽ có 2
cách để làm điều này
ở đâu ạ thì cách đầu tiên thì mình
thường hay làm đó là mình sẽ tạo duyệt
thuê ship với thăm nhà với ở đây Các bạn
thấy bài đăng đúng không ạ Mình sẽ tạo
relationship với thằng bài đăng đấy
thằng có nhiều bài đăng đầu chứ vào đây
sẽ có ghi tên goroth Harmony là có nhiều
đúng hạn ở đây sẽ chửa post cái này là
sau thằng cò như vậy anh không ạ
ừ ừ
được rồi
thêm chữ s Được rồi Ok ờ ờ
theo post thì các bạn sẽ lấy tất cả bài
đăng đúng trước tất cả bài đã theo từng
Nhu dơ đúng ạ đây tôi sẽ chụp Perry đây
này à
ạ sau đó thì which fastyie trả lại
đúng chứ Thì tôi sẽ lấy tất cả bà đang
theo từng vụ giờ luôn
xe khách hay nhiều class
không gọi cho anh rồi đó Ừ thế thôi à
để tạo thành một em post ở
ở khu đô mi Yo
Hà Nội nhựa ít nhất nhỉ
có lệnh chai vậy
PT hack
Ừ ok
à à
Anh ấy thì bây giờ sẽ ra toàn bộ bài
đăng có cấu da có nhiều bài đang cẩu rơi
ít về đăng nhưng mà bây giờ tôi không
quan trọng điều đấy thôi Quan trọng là
xem câu truy vấn đã thì sẽ telescopes
này à
ừ ừ
thêm vài cái nữa cách lắp ít nữa
- store xong rồi có biểu thức
a Minecraft Minecraft rồi
đó kia rồi đây cô dâu của tôi đây nhà
ông sẽ thấy là à
ca nhạc ai quay đi đây nó sẽ lấy toàn bộ
Loser sau đó lấy toàn bộ bài đăng que in
trong danh sách toàn bộ user này đúng
chợ thì ở đây
anh
[âm nhạc]
ở đây thì à
cho tôi lại không muốn lấy tất cả các
bài đăng của nó mà tôi chỉ muốn lấy toàn
bộ à
khi sex
an toàn bộ đếm toàn bộ bài đăng thì có
một cái rất là hay của nó đó là Quýt Cao
nó sẽ đến hộ trong toàn bộ tất cả bài
đăng như thế này
áo da xịn
có thể chạy thử cho bé uống xem em
các bạn nó sẽ có hồi nó sẽ không lấy chả
vẹn mả đây như vừa nãy mà sẽ tốt cao nha
luôn này Đấy bạn này đã đang được 81 bài
này có sự thứ đoạn thì câu truy vấn nó
sẽ khác họ sẽ là như thế này
a selects uzair chấm Sao này là lấy tất
cả các cột ở trong bảng Oh dơ sau đó đi
Safari ở lấy thêm một câu truy vấn nữa
đến bài pass mặc định là mình đang se
Lac form use nhưng với với từng user 1
với từng bản ghi Minh lại thỏ thêm một
câu truy vấn nữa với để lấy số lượng bài
đăng ở trong bằng post cái sắp có ghi
này không tốt ở điểm là bây giờ xử là là
tôi đang có rất nhiều rất nhiều dơ thì
nó lại phải chạy bấy nhiêu lần cái vòng
lập để mà lấy ra bỏ vào trong bài bài
đăng đấy bé thứ mà tôi không muốn
thứ hai à Nhưng mà Ừ trước hết táo để
tôi thêm những điều kiện vào trong đầy
cho bé Ông cảm thấy là nó sẽ chuẩn hơn
bởi vì anh như tôi vừa bảo lúc đầu là
tôi muốn lấy là thật chứ ạ đấy toàn bộ
bài đăng ngày hôm nay đếm toàn bộ váy
đăng ngày hôm nay và đến toàn bộ bài
đang trong tháng này thì sẽ như nào thì
mình sẽ ở đây khi mà quýt như này thì
mình sẽ có phong trần như ai nữa
cử tạ từ này quy đấy tôi sẽ không chuyển
thêm điều kiện rồi đây là sự là giả sử
là sử là thằng lao là hỗ trợ những cái
Hà rất hay này Sự là ông thật chứ ông
Wen ở đây Where
weight đ
à à
chị lại gọi nó gợi ra luôn à da xịn tí
Đợi tôi một tí nhá
mình có cố kê Tấn đồng loạt các từ cấp
lớn hơn bằng đấy
một ngày sẽ lớn hơn bằng à
anh ở đây có Thứ nhất là tôi không thích
dùng Cacbon trong trường hợp này lao là
nó là cái Hàn của carbon
và đương nhiên nó tiện nhưng mà vì tôi
là dùng hàm có sẵn của pp đó sẽ nhanh và
nhẹ hơn trong hộp này tôi sẽ đổi nó là
đến như thế này à
Ừ cái này giả sử Tôi muốn nó là đến
trong
ở Xuân Mai
một trước đây rồi ạ tốt cao Today
như thế này à
Ừ thì à mình sẽ lớn hơn bằng cho mày hôm
nay ngay đúng ạ thậm chí ở mấy ông còn
thêm điều kiện cho thằng này được là sử
là tôi muốn xa tốt bắt buộc sao tốt phải
là mua thôi chẳng ạ thì sẽ que
status à
à à
chị sẽ là bằng bột Thôi tôi chạy thử cho
bé uống xem nhé á
ừ ừ
này nó phải ghi ra Cầm như này vậy
ở đâu đấy
thì À cái này mấy ông hoàn toàn thể xem
thêm ở chế tài liệu của Lazio nhé Cái
này là là thuê ship
đó xong rồi bạn chất có thể ích cows âm
tính đó không thể truyền thêm có chữ vấn
vào cái ông ạ này
ý là tôi cho bé uống xem câu truy vấn
này có chứ vẫn Lần này thì nó đã nó đã
thêm những cái điều kiện cho tôi là
A theo điều kiện ở đây được ạ Đúng kiểu
như này và nó dùng làm đếch gì mà kéo
lấy ra ngày so sánh với ngài hãy tha thứ
bí quyết tịch này của tôi nó sẽ có cả
giờ phút giây là nó so sánh Nếu mà thấy
biết nữa Nó sẽ chuột hơn sẽ chuẩn hơn
thịt gà không không cần nhìn nó vẫn chạy
được đấy bởi vì nếu mà theo nếu mà ông
theo đúng format thì thực ra ông không
cần dùng đến cũng được nhờ tôi đang muốn
nói thứ nhất đó là
Ừ cái này liên quan đến bài toán tôi tôi
đang chỉ cho mấy ông từ việc chả làm
được nhé rồi tôi sẽ còn chị ông cái tối
ưu nhé Okay tiếp theo là mình sẽ có là
thế nếu cho Tháng này thì sao ạ thì ở sẽ
là
zissman đúng không ạ
Ừ sáng nay bạn để làm thì có thể bạn ấy
thể chơi theo cách này là Where như thế
này so sánh với Nam hiện tại như này và
tiếp theo là quay mắt như thế này rồi so
sánh với năm hiện tại cũng là một cách
hay cũng có một cái hai rồi thứ hai mà
chạy thử này
ừ ừ
xe tải xe cọp boltzmann như thế này xem
câu truy vấn
portege và một câu truy vấn nữa sắp Kali
nữa để lấy
u-ear Mà em ăn như thế này ok chưa thì
đây mà chỉ đơn giản là ông lấy ra được
thôi Còn tối ưu thì mới ông thể đã có sự
lặp lại ở đây và không tối ưu chúng chưa
Nhất là surgery không những là một sắc
free về ông chưa thật hay Safari cái thứ
nhất thứ hai đó là là tôi không khuyên
mấy ông nên dùng và Yemen 2dat như này
để mà so sánh kiểu này nữa bởi vì sao
Bởi vì nếu là lịch sử về sau ông làm
việc với cái cốc này ông que theo cuộn
mà nhiều thường của tôi sẽ đánh đất cho
Cuộn này và nếu mà đánh cái quần này thì
chỉ nó giảm đáng để cho giá trị cụ này
thôi chứ Vậy ạ phải như đất cho cái việc
là ông đã dùng hàm đết hay dùng một bất
kỳ cái Hà mà khác liên quan cục này nó
khác nhau với nhá nghĩa là ông cả nhiên
đấy Cho còn này đúng không thì khi mà
ông Wen theo cột này thì đúng rồi nhanh
còn nếu bông que theo một cái hàm nữa
dùng giá trị của mày như thế này thì nó
không Không được đánh nách thì nó không
có ý nghĩa gì cả em vẫn sẽ chậm được
không ạ Nghĩa à
Ừ nếu thấy việc đánh lấy của ông Khánh
xài nên là tôi khi mà đánh Index như thế
này thì tôi sẽ không dùng cái hàm
Ừ tôi sẽ không dùng cái hàm kuad như này
nữa cho dù thằng lao đúng là nó có gợi ý
nhưng mà
đúng là nó có nhu cầu sẽ không dùng vệ
dùng như nào rồi lấy ngày hôm nay nó bạn
thì tôi sẽ chỉ lớn hơn bằng thời gian
hiện tại như này là được rồi Như tôi vẫn
nói thứ hai đó là nếu và list ăn đây rồi
loạn thì tôi sẽ copy cái này
khi tôi đổi cái này cái này anh cháu nối
chuỗi cậu nhà màn hình lớn hơn ngày 01
là được đúng trước ảnh như này nó sẽ chỉ
có là lớn nốt ngày hôm nay lớn hơn ba
ngày hôm nay hoặc lớn hơn bằng 5 và
tháng này tại bắt đầu từ ngày đầu tiên
đúng chưa Đấy thế là xong
anh có truy vấn thì nó sẽ khác khác một
tí nó sẽ như thế này
em vẫn sẽ là so sánh thẳng như lại luôn
thì cái được đánh lên đấy của nhé thứ
hai tiếp theo ở cái này mình tạo ra cái
đất mới và nó và nó sẽ hiểu con heo
director thứ em bởi vì a ngày hôm nay
lại trùng vào đầu đầu tháng nên thành ra
nó Bích kiểu lặp lại trong nó hơi bị
buồn cười thôi chứ không béo gửi tôi mà
không ạ ấy tiếp theo là như tôi bảo là
cái này Safari và đối với axwell thì sắp
huy nó sẽ khi họ sẽ không tối ưu vàng
roi và nó sẽ nặn hơn đấy thế bây giờ
mình sẽ kết hợp với việc ạ Dùng roi và
kết hợp với có thêm những cái điều kiện
thì mình làm nhà tớ sẽ thử cho bé uống
xem em đó để sang một bên Nga
ẩn hay đi này
tôi sẽ làm gì ở đây tôi sẽ doi
do em đâu rồi Thằng boss loạn ạ Và ở đây
Tôi có một cái rất hay Tôi sẽ gọi đây là
xinh như này tôi sẽ dùng chi Tôi thường
kiểu on như này boss chấm Urê đi bằng
bằng Bây giờ mày đi đúng chứ tiếp theo
là tôi sẽ có gì were như này sao tất
I must sẽ bằng bột
anh đấy à
Ừ để tôi sẽ chạy thử cho bé ông sai ở
máy ông hình dung hơn khi mà
Ừ đúng nghĩa là bây giờ nếu mà cho như
thế này nó sẽ trả về giống
3000 có chơi lỗi rỗng Ừ cái bìa tôi chưa
quen là tháng này chưa rỗng Vì sao Ý tôi
là
ngọn nhưng mà nó sẽ trả về hơn nhiều một
hơn hơn 1 other mày ông mà ông thấy là
nó sẽ kiểu ID Cái này như có bị thay đổi
lại đi lại đi vào bài đăng thì tôi Thứ
nhất là tôi chỉ muốn lấy nếu méo để kia
tôi chỉ muốn lấy other sao thôi chứ
không phải lấy toàn bộ thông tin của bà
đang nữa thì mình sẽ là tới thưởng này
dụng axetic chứ không dùng seneque mấy
nữa Do chấm Sao đúng trước
đăng có thứ thì trả về nè
ừ ừ
Điệp lại mình Đức bởi vì sao rồi mình
roi vào mà nhớ vào thừa mình cho ở đây
có được mình cao để đến thôi Đây là
thường là mình sẽ phải goodbye hello
goodbye theo user
queo thì nó làm được cái trò là có thể
lấy những cái cột không nằm trong Good
bye giả sử như một nê phải không nằm
trong Goodbye vẫn thể lấy được chứ thằng
We're Super nó sự chặt chẽ hơn được vụ
này sẽ chích hơn vụ này đó Bây giờ nếu
thấy nó sẽ chỉ có ra một thôi Tại sao
lại chỉ ra một bởi vì chỉ có đúng mỗi
cái ông này là ông đăng bài để mẫu một
lời đó tất cả thì ông sẽ dụng navdroyd
để nó tất cả kể cả người không đăng bài
gì cũng lấy ra từ trước đó thì nó sẽ hết
ok chưa Nếu mà Cái này mới chỉ có giải
quyết là Ừ ok Bây giờ vẫn đấy ra toàn bộ
thông tin thủ dâm hay còn đếm số của bài
đăng của em đâu Đúng bạn thì bây giờ
mình sẽ làm
Ừ thì bạn chất ở đây là mình sẽ phải que
theo như thế này và tôi sẽ ôm cái côve à
bình tĩnh gì sẽ cho ông xem có truyền
phần hai lá có Trụ phần nha
Anh ơi nó có choi này béo để ký ở đây đó
là ngoài việc là tôi lấy tất cả ozo này
tôi cho với thằng post tôi đã que thêm
một phát nữa là post status bằng một Nếu
mẹ mỉ kỹ càng were này tôi rõ ràng ghi
Ủa em nhé nhưng nó không thể có que ở
trong câu chuyện này đúng bạn nếu để kéo
về quê trong câu truy vấn đề đâu Cái này
nó làm tất cả sao Ờ
minh hơn đoạn này thì chắc chắn là nó sẽ
có que và chỉ lấy những cái bài đăng có
cost bằng 1
cho tôi tôi à Tôi vẽ cho mày ông dễ hình
dung đi
ờ ờ
ừ đấy giờ vẽ rồi nếu béo nhiều vẽ thằng
Tí Gần đây tôi có tập user là thế này
này một tập user toàn bộ những khách
hàng của tôi đúng ạ à Nhưng mà
vì số lượng số lượng Urê thực sự đăng
bài đúng ạ thì nó chỉ
em nằm trong cây sáng ngày hội sẽ bé hơn
rất nhiều nó xuống lượng người đăng bài
làm sao là lớn hơn tổng số lượng tất cả
u rơi được đúng chứ Đấy
vì số lượng user có đăng bài và sẽ chị
Bé ngay đúng chứ Thế làm nào để lấy cái
số lượng này thì bản chất là mình thường
này dùng roi à mình sẽ dùng đắp cho vào
nhớ bạn Nếu nhớ với cái hình ảnh rep cho
các thứ rồi đấy thì
ở đây nó là cái cái những cái bài đăng
này nó lại còn có tập con nữa như này nó
sẽ là thật con là gì đó là những cái bài
đăng có sắp tốt là một và chỉ nằm trong
cái tháng này hay nằm trong ngày hôm nay
họ sẽ chị Bé ngay thôi đấy thì ước bây
giờ một là ông sẽ dùng toàn bộ user này
này ông reg Ôi cái hàng to là lấy nét
roi toàn bộ bài Bush là bao gồm cả việc
là sao tấn bằng bao nhiêu đi nữa và
không phải trong tháng này hay ông muốn
mà chỉ có do I với cái thằng bé bé thôi
là sắp tới bằng một tất cả
nằm trong tháng nay thôi Âm Nhạc
em lấy có hai cái Đúng không Một là ông
Urê của ông đây đúng không Ông cho với
toàn bộ tất cả bài đăng hay là ông chỉ
cho đến một lượng bài đăng nằm trong
tháng này thôi rõ ra là ông sẽ nghĩ là ở
cho cái lượng này nó sẽ ít hơn vì sao
mấy ông hình dung cho là bản chất là nó
sẽ nó sẽ ánh xạ giá trị Xa của nó không
có 5 Maurer có 10 vừa đăng thì nó sẽ tạo
ra là dụng 15 15 Bởi vì ở đây mối quan
hệ một nhiều nên thấy ra không phải nơ
này ra nó sẽ là 15 cái bản ghi Vâng ạ
nhưng mà nó sẽ ánh xạ từ Nhu dâu với
từng bài đăng Thế bây ngay từ lúc đầu
bài đăng ở bên này đã được lọc ít rồi nó
chỉ còn 5 bà ấy chẳng ạ thì number với 5
bài đăng nó sẽ dễ hơn ạ
Ừ đấy thì bây giờ làm cái ở tôn lọc
trước cái post đã sau đó đi tôi Mình soi
thì tôi sẽ kiểu sẽ làm như này
tôi thường này có khái niệm nó là sắp
sắp cho rồi
an toàn bộ những cái này ra hơi bị nâng
cao một tí nhưng mà không phải ai cũng
dậy rồi đây tôi sẽ nói qua cho mày ông
ờ ờ trò sắp chứ ra thế
gà chọi sắt gọi này nói cho sóc ông sẽ
ông sẽ ghi câu truy vấn về cái post này
trước xong roi với nó sẽ post bằng post
như này
I Were In ông sẽ que như bình thường
trước khỏe này à
ờ ờ
ý mày sao tất cả thứ thử ngày trước
Ừ nó
Em ở đây em sẽ rep cho sắp đã được đó
sau đó thì ông chỉ cần ghi vào đây sau
Tiếp theo là ông sẽ on theo cái gì
Ừ ông nếu mà ông đơn giản ông ô theo
đúng như mọi khi ông ngon như thế này
thì ông không cần phải ghi cái phong
trên nữa ông thể chỉ đơn giản là đi là
nghe thôi
xe
tải topec hẳn các công trình như vừa rồi
nó sẽ ra cậu tạo ra một cái này cho này
cũng gọi là sắp Đấy nét cho sắp và cái
này nhưng cái này nó sẽ viết câu truy
vấn nó sẽ khác ông nghĩ kĩ câu truy vấn
như này nhá chạy thử lại cho ông xem nhé
đây
cài bất cứ cái gì khác để xem có truy
vấn đề ông để ý nhá xem chị Vân nó khác
nhé
có một cái là lép voi show Em theo như
thế này thì bản chất thằng thằng
sportsline nó sẽ chưa được lọc chưa được
lọc giống như ở tôi vẽ ở đây là cách
pizza đây cũng sẽ lấy hết ông sẽ doi hai
thằng với nhau rồi mình que thì ở cái
file port này còn ở trong trường hợp Thứ
hai này là ông lấy ông ông lấy kể
thaipost bạn xa tới bằng một trước rồi
Đã đấy Cái ông lấy cái Thăng thằng bé bé
như này trước đã rồi đấy cho ông lấy
xăng to roi đúng với mỗi thằng bé thôi
Đấy thấy không em
à Còn như bình thường câu truy vấn nó
dài hơn trông có vẻ dài hơn Đúng trước
nhưng là sẽ Tôi yêu hơn ở điểm là thằng
này nó là một cái bảng bé ông cho cái
bảng 2 bảng bé với nhau thì nó sẽ không
bằng 1 bằng bằng to sống cho bằng to
thậm chí rằng uzair Này ông còn thể khoe
cái gì đó để cho nó bé dồi dào thông bé
nữa cũng được đấy có rất nhiều cách
tải ông Ông Chà trên mạng cái được
rồi Sắp xem bao nhiêu người dạy không
thì mình rồi đấy ạ
a tiếp theo nha
pr thực tế hai hàng này nó một điểm
chung nữa
ừ thì của em rồi nè Đó là à
cách viết để nó thành tối ưu chứ không
phải nó tự gọt tự động Tôi yêu mình đôi
khi nó tự động cũng chưa hẳn là chuẩn
lắm đâu
ờ ờ hai thằng này nó Điểm chung nữa là
nó đều nằm trong tháng này chẳng qua là
một thằng cụ thể ngày hơn hôi một tháng
thì à là ngày mà chị ngày hôm nay như là
tôi thường và sáng nay tôi vợ ý bạn đấy
là sẽ mặc định là lớn hơn lấy nằm trong
tháng này đã như thế này
sau đó thì tôi sẽ có select all này
cao
hát này
moscow's unnie có chạy thứ mấy ông xe
mày
không thấy có Pascal zmin ở đã lên đường
trước
em chạy lại
mà đếm mà và mình mặc định qua thêm một
điều kiện nữa như này để lấy toàn bộ
những bài đăng trong tháng nay thôi thì
cái lượng này nó còn bé hơn rất nhiều
nữa sau cái vạch post vừa nãy đây là roi
này còn nhanh hơn nhưng nếu để ý kĩ là
cao sao đây nó bị sai bởi Việt ở khu dân
lại không thể đăng bài nhưng mà cao xa ở
đây là đang đến tất cả nó say nên cao ở
đây thường là tôi sẽ cao không phải có
sao mà tôi sẽ cao ở đây là cao chính
theo cái cụt và mình mình sẽ do như thế
này sẽ cao cột này thì nó sẽ ra đứng
giữa Đúng
là như này
Ừ thế là trong tháng ai chẳng ai đánh
bay cả đúng ạ tôi thể cho tôi thử thay
đổi đi cái một bài đăng tôi đổi thời
gian nó sẽ ra à
Rồi nó thành tháng này nước
lớn hơn tận ngày ngày hôm nay đúng không
xem xem
khi uống giờ đăng bài này là ai đã
Ừ giời đi Đúng rồi nhỉ
Forest Man
Ừ Ok đó của bạn đang bạn như là không
phải ngày hôm nay đúng ạ Có cái theo
tiếp theo là bây giờ mình
ạ Bây giờ thì mấy ông sẽ bảo anh que
theo cậu lớn hơn trong tháng ai mất rồi
Thêm bây giờ nếu mà cao để mà lấy trong
ngày hôm nay thì sao thì đây nó sẽ lại
thêm một cái nữa
Ừ
tôi sẽ không dùng cao và thường là đối
với excel của trước cá ông được học thì
ra thì ông ấy kiểm tra dùng ít keo nếu
mà nó nếu loạn nếu mà nó đúng thì tăng
lên một thì nó sẽ là khái niệm khái niệm
ở trong lập trình này nó sẽ khái niệm
không phải là cao nữa hộ cháu cái xe nó
cao ít ý lấy ông Nếu mà Mấy ông biết
Excel cao ít để mà kiểm tra nếu mà nếu
mà đúng thì tăng thì đến là một đấy thì
trong Word nó không có khái niệm cao ít
nhưng nó khái niệm xăm ít thì mình sẽ là
như nào cũng sẽ dùng hàm xăm và kiểm tra
ở trong này nó cũng không có ít luôn mà
dùng case Where
mình sẽ quên như thế nào mình sẽ quen ở
đây là
cái nó hơi bị Hơi bị à
Ừ tôi thường này So sánh đây này
lớn hơn bằng gì này và
tủ bếp
khi y mắn dai đấy
em tắt qua nó gợi ý là chuẩn luôn này
Đúng rồi chị ạ
ở
các câu truy vấn của tôi là chạy như này
sau khi mà cái ngày ngày hôm nay lớn hơn
bằng à cái ngay ngày tạo lớn nó bằng này
không ai thật thì tôi sẽ tăng lên 1
anh như này cái Xuka thì hơi bị sai thì
rõ ràng là phải Bằng ngày hôm nay thì
mới đúng
này bằng lại thằng mày đi đấy
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Những Kẻ Thừa không cần em đâu ạ
áo ren một như thế này tao nghe một hiệu
thôi
nha
anh gọi
Ừ nó
tôi xem nhé
thủ thuật đeo đây không đi để cho nó
không ra luôn ý
ở đó
anh em mỗi tội nó ra kiểu dạng không kệ
đi nhé
em không có không có bossa đây đó ạ sử
về tôi xử đổi một cái poster đây sẽ khai
nhé Để đây là ngày 19
hình như là cái tay ở liên quan đến khi
nó bằng bằng ấy Tôi nghĩ là do cái dấu
bằng lấy bằng bác buộc phải bằng cái
tuyệt đối Nó bảo không không giờ ấy tao
ra thì cả
không có bài đăng
à à
anh không có bài đăng nào nó chơi kiểu
dạng là tạo ra trước này cả tận hôm 16
này cả nghe tôi thường là chỉ cần lớn
hơn bằng được rồi nhưng nếu là sử các
bạn muốn chơi kiểu cho chắc cú đi mấy
ông sẽ có thể như thế này
Ừ để lấy ra chính xác so sánh thời gian
thì nó sẽ ra
ừ ừ
à mà không để điều khiển nó xem lại xem
có gì sai sai đây nhá boss street
ảnh
hot girl thật
à À rồi
thì tại sao ở đây nó dùng một cách ra
của tôi nhỉ
Anh
nhớ nó
anh sex pro men's emerge vào được nhỉ Tự
nhiên là cách tra của cái đây tôi thấy
nhớ sai này
tôi so sánh với chuối mình quen con sẽ
nháy rồi đấy
à à
với
thời gian nó vẫn ở chỗ nhé vẫn phải cho
trong là chuỗi ok chưa thấy phải xem cái
t Scott thì biết được câu truy vấn mình
đúng hay sai thì nó sẽ ra cái gì thậm
chí à
ở đây mèo không Để ý kỹ à Tôi sẽ xào đấy
Thức hơi nhiều Tôi không cần chế sao đây
mình sẽ chỉ cần xà lách mỗi cột để mà
mình sẽ do lỗi cả cột cuối tự tắt thôi
sẽ là
sẽ lấy cả đây mình ạ
Em dậy đi và khuyết tật ấp Thế thôi hai
cái hai cái để mình sẽ xử lý Chắc còn
hơn với gì cả
em ở nhà thì
sau khi mà câu truy vấn mình ra cái kết
quả quấy nó sẽ như thế này à có một cái
là đầu tiên là mình sẽ Shake như này
mình sẽ đến toàn bộ tất cả bài đăng
chị sẽ lấy trong ngày trong tháng này
không ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ mình sẽ
+ + từng cái một tăng tăng lên một tăng
lên một với từng Nhu dơ nha từng newsid
Nếu mà đang còn đang trong ngày hôm nay
đúng bạn
đấy xong rồi Khi mà rat doi mình sẽ ghép
trôi với cái Bạn post chỉ lấy những cái
cột mình cần và Vĩnh worst ất ơ
cho các thứ để nó chắc chắn mà cái phải
bóp sức nó sẽ có ghi dữ liệu hưởng ok
chưa ạ
dùng phèn có sẵn
thì nó sẽ không đủ tối ưu bằng việc cả
ông phải ghi tách ra rồi ai à
ấy cần là tối ưu thêm các câu lệnh Đã
thử thứ Cốt đã thử như thế này còn nợ án
ông bé không có kiểu dưới 100.000 Màn
Ghi thì ông được cao dùng này có sẵn là
chạy ngon sẽ vượt rồi
em lấy cái này à Bạn hãy hỏi tôi tôi
muốn tôi giải đáp cho các bạn một mình
xem thế này vẫn mơ hồ quá ông anh à
Em à bây giờ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn
với tài liệu nhé sau đó thì hôm các bạn
còn tâm sự gì nữa tâm sự nốt không đi
Chúng ta đã dán à
ừ ừ
ok ờ
các bạn tâm sự hay cảm ơn gì đó tự cảm
động cảm thấy rất không ra mình vẫn là
có vẻ Đang cố ích
Ai bảo ông ngồi núi cao lắm mà nó sắp
qua đi mà ờ
từ tài liệu
xe tải điện
à à
thế à
ờ
ờ các bạn Các bạn nhớ phải tuân theo
những cái quy tắc này làm tài liệu đấy ạ
em thậm giữa tài liệu nó bắt buộc chỉ
dùng số La Mã đánh số này còn không dùng
kí tự đặc biệt gì gió cơ nếu là nếu kiểu
in sách xin cậu sách giáo khoa ấy à
ờ ờ
đề tài liệu
sơ đồ các thứ thứ các bạn cứ làm lại
giống như hồi trước mình làm được
nữa mà ok ở đây
chắc là cái đồ ăn hay thì cái toàn bộ
tính năng ngoài này thì các bạn sẽ hiểu
sẽ đổ phân tích rõ cho mình những kẻ
tính năng nào thích nhau mà bạn cảm
dọn nhà
anh nói chung là gần như ở toàn bộ những
cái tính năng này gần như có tính năng
nào chính ra của em Các bạn là các bạn
sẽ phải phân tích
nên nó sẽ rất dài nên là sẽ có nhiều cái
các bạn Thể gộp chung các tác nhân có
thể thứ và mô tả đó có thể không không
cần nhiều quá dài rằng những nhưng mà
bắt buộc có tính đang ở trên trang web
các bạn các bạn đều phải có phân tích ở
đây bởi vì bắt bỏ Tài liệu này chứ
bắt buộc phải có trước khi có phần mềm
liên hoàn thành ra là
giữ đầy đủ chứ không thể là ông có phần
mềm xong rồi còn rất nhiều một cái mà
không hề nằm trong làn điệu thì sẽ sai
mục đích rồi tài liệu là thận chế viết
để về sau còn đọc để hiểu qua phần mềm
nên bắt buộc à có tính năng gì mức chỉ
có tính năng gì đều phải có nằm trong
tài liệu này và cái này tôi sẽ
Ừ
nhưng mà Bởi vì ở chắc à
chủ đề nộp của tôi nếu mà giả sử giống
như hồi trước của bọn tôi làm là tôi
phải in anh Quyền đấy thì cha à còn phải
nộp cho nhà trường thì tra cần mày đầy
đủ hơn
anh nhớ gọi điện nó có tôi thì tôi đang
nghĩ là có khi là giảm bớt ở trong miệng
ông mà ông cha chỉ cần phân tích ra tôi
những cái tính năng quan trọng ở trên
trang web của mình ông thôi còn những
tính năng xem như xóa anh đăng nhập mà
không không sử dụng những cái gì đó hiểu
qua phức tạp theo kiểu đã Pocket gì đó
hai á đăng nhập một mạng xã hội khác thì
mới ông thể tạm giảm tại của tôi nhưng
mà
Ừ nhưng mà tôi đang vẫn nói theo kiểu
lại bé Nộp tài liệu tôi thì chỉ cần đơn
giản thế nhưng mà còn là về sau ông làm
dự án thực tế là ông có bao nhiêu tính
năng sẽ phải phân tích các thứ thứ phải
chi tiết ra để công việc của bia ấy
ông nào muốn làm bia thì ông sẽ thể quen
việc làm tài liệu này
khi sex
Ừ
con đâu tất cả những cái còn lại cha à
Thế ông nhìn cái này cũng hiểu qua là
nhỉ Nếu mà còn thắc mắc gì về cái tài
liệu này không nhỉ từng làm đoán một thì
xa nó cũng tương đương tương đương rồi
Khá giống không khác gì cả thêm mỗi phần
mấy phần công nghệ mô tả về sẽ hay ho
hơn thôi
có tôi còn đang không mày nhé
Ừ tự nhiên tận hai cái đấy nhỉ
chủ đề sơ đồ cơ sở địa số cụ thể kiểu
tối giản Xong rồi hôm trước tôi à
anh có xem như người bà làm sơ đồ kiểu
chi tiết hơn cũng được giờ tôi nghĩ là
tôi dậy kiểu tối giản mấy ông ấy không
quen thôi chứ không phải đi motet ăn mấy
ông sẽ phải học cách lại cứ như thế này
nhá Ừ
nhỉ
ừ ừ
tạm cái đầu đấy nha
em heo còn thắc mắc gì nữa
Có gì buồm sau ạ Có nhóm nào cần mình
chữa chữa từ cốt cho đẹp tài liệu thì cứ
bình luận nhé
Ừ Ok chờ các bạn nha à